tonight president trump just wrapped up
another
massive rally yup the rallies are back
look at this video from dan scavino
do you think the biden campaign could
ever get
crowds this size just you keep watching
and keep looking at the video look at it
because
what you see that's the overflow crowd
those are the people that didn't fit
inside the massive
rally space the inside part in freeland
michigan tonight
supporters lining up around the block
and down the street we'll show it all
we've got plenty of time
according to reports some were waiting
in line for more than
24 hours we've got the highlights
president was on fire tonight along with
also tonight a full report our 2020
election correspondent lawrence jones
he is on the ground he was at the rally
tonight
also we're going to bring you breaking
news from the durham pro this is huge
mueller's team
led by of course his well hit man
andrew weissman the pit bull caught in a
massive cover-up just like hillary
clinton almost all of them
guess what they wiped their phones clean
hmm is that obstruction of justice by
team mueller we'll investigate
and are more charges on the way but
first we start with another blatant lie
from the ever forgetful joe biden now
joe actually wants americans you the
american people to believe that
he can be coveted 19 but only if you
elect him
if he remembers what it is in november
december january
he claims he sounded the alarm early on
about the deadly virus
and that president trump did everything
wrong
okay joe's lying just like his friends
in the media mob
and well most liberal democrats these
days joe biden
is living an alternative reality once
again
here are the facts that the hey trump
media mob will never give you will do
their job for them
in late january just days before the
president issued
what was the unprecedented china travel
ban
and first quarantine in 50 years 10 days
after the first identified case in this
country well
biden's top advisor his name is ron
klein
he was actually praising china's
transparency
huh watch this i think what you have to
say about china is
it's been more transparent and more
candid than it has been
during past outbreaks though still there
are problems with transparency and
candor
okay remember so it's the same china
where zero experience
hunter biden got the sweetheart 1.5
billion dollar deal from the bank of
china you know not deutsche bank not
goldman sachs
uh not chase uh no that would be
joe biden hunter his son quid pro quo
joe sucking up to hunter he's
compromised by china
peter schweitzer has identified this in
detail
and so on january 28th three days before
the president's travel ban just seven
days after the first identified case
this same biden health advisor said that
he opposed the travel ban
it was premature but they were on top of
it that's what they said watch
would you ban chinese travelers from
arriving in the united states
i wouldn't i think that's premature i
think it's very important
exchange very important for trade and
tourism and the very very few of those
people will have it what's more
uh you know since this virus broke out a
quarter million people have come from
china so they're already here
and then one day before the president's
travel ban january 30th
top biden health official dr zeke
emanuel said
everyone needed to stop panicking stop
being hysterical
then on february 1st that's the day that
biden day after the travel ban was
implemented
after 10 days the first identified case
corona
well joe himself tweeted out that the
travel ban was hysterical
xenophobia and fear-mongering on
february 13
topped by an advisor claimed he tweeted
that we are experiencing a fear epidemic
not a coveted 19 epidemic
joe biden himself called the president's
aggressive covert 19 response
the travel ban first quarantined in over
50 years
hysterical xenophobia fear mongering
on multiple occasions as late as march
the 18th
and meanwhile joe biden was still
holding indoor rallies in the month of
march and
he was doling out his world famous
creepy hugs remember those
he wasn't talking about social
distancing he wasn't wearing
a mask he wasn't coordinating an
aggressive use of the defense production
act plan or sourcing
uh ppe and he was against the travel ban
against the quarantine against the
subsequent travel ban
now that likely saved at least hundreds
and hundreds of thousands of americans
from contracting the virus and god knows
how many thousands of americans
from dying and by the way he didn't get
to that until
april get this biden's press secretary
now like biden blatantly lying
and pretending that the ever forgetful
joe
was always in favor of the travel ban
that's called the lie
the ban that they called joe multiple
times including
late march hysterical xenophobic
fear-mongering take a look
you're saying that joe biden was for
closing down travel from china when the
president did it
uh joe biden has been clear and i can
send you the fact checks if they're
helpful
brad joe biden has been clear that he
was not against that travel ban but he
was for it
joe biden has been clear about this
brett again i can send i can send you
the fact checks
if they're helpful this has been fact
checked into oblivion okay i'm just
asking you the question
you're saying yes he was for the china
travel ban when the president
implemented it two 48 hours after
receiving that briefing
the important thing about the travel ban
yes or no yes i know
and i know brett i know that you all
like to cite the travel brand i know
that no no the
the important thing to know about the
travel ban is that even after the
president implemented that travel ban
tens or says that he implemented it tens
of thousands of people
came in and that you're not going to
answer that question you're going to
send me some fact checks
rep bear has the patience of job there
because he's lying
and everybody knows it in other words
joe biden did everything wrong
but now he's gonna lie about it and hope
that you will all
forget what really happened you know i
love the woodward hysteria you know
about bob woodward's book
yeah uh the president said he wanted to
calm fears in america
what do we have to fear but fear itself
fdr said at the height of
the great depression world war ii
remember those tough days
churchill you know the bombing of
britain out marching with the people of
britain
uh was he talking well get them in the
hills and everywhere blood tile tears
and sweat
that's what leaders do biden is saying
no this is hysterical xenophobia fear
mongering
he offered no solutions nothing new for
biden
and his team to lie by the way imagine
if prep bear was actually questioning
joe biden there
that would be that would be tv
pay-per-view from deep funding to police
he lies about that
reallocation he calls it uh uh
fracking oh against it against it but no
i was always for it
protests oh yeah no they're peaceful
until well
it's showing up badly in the polls
national mass mandate
well joe biden said oh no i don't want
that either
okay he lies about pretty much every
position he's
ever taken only if it helps him
politically
only if the polls and focus groups tell
him what to say like
don lemon advised him to listen to but
here's what's more concerning
joe biden is actually really
weak and frail and doesn't seem mentally
alert or on top of his game doesn't seem
to have a lot of
well let's say mental acuity just listen
to biden's top advisor
the guy you just heard from ron klain
saying that the biden obama response
listen to what they admitted about their
response to the h1n1 virus not the n1 h1
viruses biden calls it take a look
i wasn't involved directly in the h1n1
response but i i lived through it as a
white house staffer
and what i will say about it is a bunch
of really talented really great people
working on it and we did every possible
thing wrong
and it's you know 60 million americans
got h1n1
uh in that period of time and it's just
purely a fortuity that this isn't one of
the great mass casualty events in
american history
had nothing to do with us doing anything
right just had to do with luck
they did everything wrong then they
didn't prepare for the next
real pandemic make no mistake 50 years
in the swamp
joe biden is now more incompetent than
ever nobody our own lawrence jones 2020
correspondent on the ground that he's
ever interviewed
has been able to identify a single
accomplishment in 50 years of joe biden
in the swamp
that has made life better for you the
american people
i could spend the entire show talking
about donald trump's promises made
promises kept and records shattered
especially on the issue of
unemployment and building the wall and
originalists on the supreme court
new trade deals and pulling out of
protracted wars and defeating the
caliphate solemni al baghdadi and
associates
and al-qaeda leaders all over the world
biden lied again this week he said over
nearly 6 200 u.s military members died
from corona
well he's wrong again well there have
been exactly
seven military deaths from covet 19. not
nearly 6 200.
without a teleprompter the ever
forgetful joe can barely communicate
today president trump had a few
observations
about biden's well precious teleprompter
take a look at this
as we continue to follow the
science-based approach to
protect our people and vanquish the
virus joe biden continues to use the
pandemic
for political gain every time i see him
he starts talking about their pandemic
he's reading the norfolk teleprompter
i'm not allowed to use a teleprompter
why is that phil
they ask questions and he starts reading
the teleprompter
he says move the teleprompter a little
bit closer please
i don't know i think if i did that i'd
be in big trouble i think that would be
that would be the story of the year
teleprompter can you can you can you
move it down
the teleport move i have to read the
answer
president is right and get this
apparently biden's teleprompters not
just for speeches
because it looks an awful like like he's
using
it to answer supposedly unscripted
questions
just listen to biden's press secretary
from earlier today this is another great
moment
has joe biden ever used a teleprompter
during local interviews
or to answer q and a with supporters
brett we are not going to engage this is
this is straight from the trump campaign
exactly they're using it and what it
does and what it does brett is it's
trying to distract the american people
i'm just
they're using it they talk about it
every day can you say yes or no that's
because they talk about it every day
right because they don't have
a coherence well you have an answer yes
or no
brett they talk about it every day
because they don't have a coherent
argument for why donald trump deserves
re-election
but you can't answer the question brett
i am not going to allow
a trump campaign to funnel their
questions through fox news
and get me to respond to that does he
use the teleprompter to answer a
question
yes or no simple question that's what
you call an evasive non-answer
because he'd have to lie again i think
we all know why his campaign is trying
to limit
his extemporaneous comments just look at
what happened wednesday
joe had to go off script a little
troubling
i want to thank you all i carry with me
i don't have it i gave gave it to my
staff but i carry with me
in my pocket hey do i have that
around anyone where's my staff
i gave it away anyway i carry a schedule
in my pocket
hold these truths to be self-evident old
man created equal and doubt by
the the thing thing you know
come on man come on you a junkie
okay gets worse at a different event
wednesday biden couldn't even remember
what taxes he wants to raise we know
it's trillions but he doesn't remember
which ones whatever they get
put in front of me i'll sign it take a
look
if you change the tax rate it went from
38 to 21.
you just send it back to 20 over to 38
down if you're 36 28.
that's what we started to try to do he
went down to 21.
truth is we have an information crisis
in the country this is serious we don't
have any real
journalists at fake news cnn msdnc
any of the newspapers networks abc nbc
nbc
state-run democratic socialist tv
biden's constant struggles if it was
donald trump i promise
it would be a huge story instead
washington post more focused on praising
kamala harris on her shoe choice very
important story
meanwhile major networks devoted 16
minutes to smearing president trump
guess how many minutes they devoted to
his nobel peace prize nomination
zero and while the mob and the media
they're doing whatever they can do to
prop up the ever forgetful joe president
trump
he's on fire he's on offense tonight he
did something
joe biden simply cannot do actually
hold a real rally deliver a long
forceful speech in front of a massive
crowd let's
dip in and take a look this is the most
important election in the history of our
country
joe biden devoted his career to
offshoring michigan's jobs
outsourcing biden supported every
disastrous globalist sellout
for over a half a century including
nafta
china and tpp you know that
joe biden surrendered your jobs to china
and now he wants to surrender our
country to the
violent left-wing mob and you're seeing
that every night
[Applause]
if biden wins china wins if biden wins
the mob
wins if biden wins the rioters anarchist
arsonists and flag burners win
[Applause]
but i wouldn't worry about it because
he's not winning i don't think
it's all on the ballot you're the
ultimate jury in 24 days oh biden's
holding virtual q a sessions on
instagram
only problem biden never actually
answered any questions per usual